hello everyone and welcome to a game i'm
pretty sure you knew i would cover uh
from round six of the 2022 tata still
chess tournament it's fabiano carwana
versus anish giri and the game features
uh okay it's not one of the greatest
blunders that were ever made but
definitely the greatest blunder that was
made uh
in a very long time especially in
classical chess this is uh i mean you
have pretty much infinite time after
after 40 moves are made you get
additional time you get 50 more minutes
on the clock then you you have the
increment i mean you can't really run
out of time in this tournament uh so the
problem with this game is that the uh
crucial blunder happened on move 40. so
one more move had to be made for the
time control to be reached uh and uh
well it it just didn't go very well for
one of the players you'll see what i
mean by this and like i said it's not
like um uh there's the uh petrossian
versus david bronstein in the 1956
candidates where queen was blundered on
d6 then there's the famous game that
we've covered carpool versus bare where
karpov just wanders mate in one there's
uh kramnik against the deep fritz i
think that was in 2008 or maybe 2006
where
uh he
blundered a mate in one uh it was that
nasty queen to h7 checkmate so there are
these incredible blunders that were made
in classical time format there are many
blunders of course in blitz and rapid
and faster time formats like uh
um vassal vancouver missing mate in one
uh against anand if you remember that
blizz game uh we've also covered it uh
so there are many examples but this is a
fresh one in the computer era and it's
uh well uh
let's check it out uh so fabi with the
white pieces opens with knight to f3 we
have another ready opening uh d5 by
anish and now b3 by fabi going for the
name so it's larson attack uh we have
bishop to f5 and now bishop to b2 so
this is all very much standard nowadays
because everyone is prepared against b3
and all of the variations of the b3
opening
we have e6 g3 h6 and bishop to g2 so
this is still also all very nice
standard theory knight to f6 castles
with bishop to e7 and now d3 preparing
to strike in the center with e4 at some
point uh we have castles and knight b to
d2 gaining more control over the e4
square a5 and now a3 we have c6 by black
and now rook to e1 we have bishop to h7
uh this bishop to h7 movie is played in
pretty much all the lines it's just a
matter of
of the move order where you want to play
it uh e4 fobby strikes in the center and
now knight beat the d7 on each
continuous development we have queen to
e2 and now queen to b6 preparing bishop
to c5 to put pressure on this f2 pawn
but okay the queen is already defending
it uh we have a4 and now comes rook f
the c8 there is a game where knight the
c5 was played but here rook after c8 is
a new move so now as of move 13 we have
a completely new game uh rook 8 to c1
and now bishop to c5 putting pressure on
that f2 pawn so you have to be a little
bit careful uh but now fabi closes the
center he plays e5 chases away the
knight knights to e8 and now knights to
f1 remaneuvering the knights to e3
we have queen to d8 by geary now freeing
up the b6 square for the knight and now
knight to e3 and here we have knight to
c7 now the knights are coming to b6 and
a6 and then you will
have some very nice control
over the queen side and here uh five we
should consider c4 to prevent this
b5 breakthrough but he goes king to h1
first a nice prophylactic idea as he
might have some plans of pushing f4 at
some point
but now he allows b5 we have knights to
d4 putting pressure on the c6 pawn now b
captures on a4 first
and now you could capture on c6 but
we're just going to move the queen and
nothing fun is happening there so b
captures on a4 and now we have knight to
b6 um
okay
it's a really complicated position and
if you load it into the engine uh it
says that knight's day six is close to
winning for anish but it's uh i mean
from a human standpoint this is very
hard to uh even imagine uh for example
okay you will put a rook on the b file
that bishop on b2 is weak and the knight
can come to for example to b4 but let's
say knight to b3 you're gonna play
bishop captures an e3 and now after
queen captures you're gonna push c5 and
uh this is uh seemingly overwhelming for
black and if you ask the anish this he
would definitely agree but i guess from
that uh position after b captures on a4
it's a bit hard to see but okay knight
the b6 was played we have rook to a1 now
defending the a4 pawn this is uh even
this kind of makes even more sense
because he moved the knight with tempo
knights the a6 and now knight to b3 so
attacking the bishop but now he doesn't
capture an e3 he goes back bishop to e7
and now as fabi prepared it the king is
on h1 he executes f4 and now he wants to
play f5 and open up the position uh so
here again c5 could be could be an idea
but fabi uh anish still waits with it he
plays king to the queen to d7 and now
fabi strikes with f5 on the king side we
have e captures on f5 and now queen to
f3 preparing to pile up on this f5 pawn
maybe rook to f1 maybe even double rooks
on the f file we're going to play bishop
to h3 and then at some point capture
this so knight the c5 offering a trade
of knights we have knight captures
bishop captures and now we have d4
chasing the bishop back bishop to e7 uh
and now bishop to h3 so putting more
pressure on that f5 pawn before we
recollect it and now we have g6
of course anisha defends this pawn but
this also means that he's uh weakening
his king side so fabi strikes with the
g4 he really wants to open up the files
for the attack and now f4
attacking this knight
asking do you maybe want to capture this
and then i'm going to play g5 and i like
my position so here we have g5 first uh
very nicely done offering the knight on
e3 and if you capture this we're just
going to play bishop captures on d7 the
queen is hanging if if you miss this
when if when g5 was played so queen to
a7 we have to move the queen and now uh
here uh fabi played bishop captures on
c8 and again the position is incredibly
complicated and a move like knights to
g4 is winning for fabi here but it's uh
it's such an ugly position that even for
an engine like fabi it's uh hard to
calculate for example bishop captures on
g5 now bishop to c1 who sees moves like
like this and now after h5 attacking the
knight knight f6 check bishop captures e
captures and look at this look at the
dark squares they're incredibly weak uh
you're gonna
you can even do something like this okay
you will not be able to check me black
black will be in time to prevent this
but it's going to be
held to defend a position like this
so instead uh fabi doesn't go for this
he plays bishop captures on c8 this is
already moved 31 and players are very
low on time you don't have all that much
time to calculate f captures on e3 in
the now we have e6 by by fabi uh if you
move the bishop back with bishop to g4
instead then we play knight c4 attack
the bishop here and when the bishop
moves bishop captures on g5 and now this
pawn is beautifully protected
by the knight and by the bishop and you
definitely have compensation for the
exchange so instead e6 by fabi going
after queen uh going after this f7 pawn
but
now anish just plays uh well uh bishop
captures on g5 now the queen guards the
f7 pawn and you should probably go for a
queen trade with queen captures an f7
but fabi plays bishop to d7 now
threatens queen captures an f7 the
bishop blocks the queen's defense of the
f7 pawn
but anis just plays f captures on uh e6
and asks uh what are what are you going
to do now so bishop captures on e6 with
check we have king to h8 and now bishop
to a3
uh this is how we activate our bishop
now the bishop can come for example to
d6 the e5 and it looks like that's it
for anisha how are you defending this
well of course we play knight to c4 this
is an absolute must for black because
you attack the bishop and also you
guarded this d6 square so
a white does not have this maneuver this
would be insane if he could play this so
queen bishop c5 attacks the queen queen
to g7 and now queen to g4 and this is
already moved 37 uh players incredibly
low on time uh three more moves need to
be made for the time control to be
reached we have bishop to f6 uh
attacking the d4 pawn well rather
putting pressure on it so far it's
nicely defended but we can always kick
away the white queen maybe so rook ate
the b1
and now comes uh g5 uh opening up the
light square bishop uh we have bishop to
f5 offering a trade and now rook to e8
they're adding another defender to the
pawn here and this is move 39 so both
players need to make one more move for
time control to be reached and here fabi
has to play something best for white is
queen h5 force that rook to move after
the rook moves you play something rook
f1 defend your bishop and the game
continues nothing special black can
still push for something but uh you know
objectively it should be fine for white
however after this rook the it move
fobby played uh like i said it's not one
of the greatest blonders ever played but
for a former 2800 player like fabi
this is just unimaginable for classical
chess but we have to keep that in mind
okay this classical chess you have
infinite time you know okay
but it's it's move 40 you still have to
play it to gain additional time because
fabi had i believe around 30 seconds on
the clock when he played it could be a
little bit more could be a little bit
less but you know not enough to you know
go into a deep thinker or something
bobby played rook to b6
that's right and we're gonna do this in
slow motion once again look at this rook
to b6 uh and he totally disregards how
the knight moves at the knight can also
capture backwards and uh well and he
just captured it knight captures uh on
b6 i will also put a link there's a
there's a video clip of this uh
chess.com even posted it on twitter so
it will be the first thing in the
description below if you want to see it
it's a one minute clip where you
basically see fabi's reaction after gary
just picks up this uh
free free exchange and he just walks up
the board and fabi you know he isn't
completed this belief uh he gained
additional time on the clock he he now
you know has all the time in the world
to play but his position is completely
lost and when i saw this okay you
immediately see the engine evaluation
saying that okay this is just trash uh
but uh
maybe there's something more to it maybe
there's there's a human component where
you know fobby can complicate something
and uh maybe it's a really deep uh
positional idea uh but it doesn't seem
to be the case because here okay bishop
captures on b6 and now anish just trades
further bishop captures on f5 queen
captures and even bishop captures on d4
and fabi's left with absolutely nothing
bishop captures an a5 okay he does have
the past a pawn but now bishop to c3
forcing a trait here as the rook is
attacked also as the bishop so bishop
captures queen captures and now uh we've
completely traded down into this uh
position where uh fabi's uh is just down
too much material unleashes up two pawns
and not only that the the pass pawn is
already on e3 and i i think fabi is so
uh i mean in such a great shock that uh
even if he could defend this for for
quite some time he he will not be able
to so here we have king to g2 uh saying
that okay you're welcome to capture my
rook here but if you capture the rook uh
then i just play queen f6 check and this
is a well-known perpetual position where
you will uh if king goes here then this
is perpetual if king goes here this is
perpetual uh you can't get out of this
uh so after king g2 queen d2 check was
played
we have king to f1 and now okay you
don't have checkmate the queen is
covering the f2 square now king g7 uh we
have queen to d7 with check now comes
king to f6 offering the rook of course
we would be happy to deliver checkmate
so queen d6 check king f5 queen d7 check
key rook to e6 blocking queen to h7
check king g4 now comes queen to f7
attacking and defending although you're
not really attacking anything you can't
leave the control of the f2 square uh so
here rook to e4 was played and he was in
this position on move 51 that fabiano
corona resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so very
very very sad for for fabita
uh you know for things to end like this
but it's not it's not completely out of
the blue uh
now
rook f4 is coming you will not be able
to keep an eye on the f2 square and
that's it you can give one more check
after the king moves there's nothing to
be done queen f5 to guard checkmate just
this and you have to give up you have to
give up the queen
and that's it so of course after rook to
e4 he resigned and um yeah for a former
2800 member uh club member in classical
chess this is unthinkable for something
like this to happen this rook the b6
move just you know
placing it in front of the knight
but this is chess things like this
happen they will always happen and it
happened here uh so just wanted you to
know that um it didn't happen like with
infinite time on the clock if i had only
seconds on the clock but still it's it's
so overwhelming that this actually
happened in classical chess
uh so yeah i could just repeat that for
for or like a hundred times because it's
so so amazing but um okay that's enough
for this video
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it always uh you know
be mindful of how the night moves uh so
hope you enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank matthew waldes mohan
alandi uh
ron swanson and tom earl for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
fine event until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day